évidemment tu vu la performance
incroyable de ma modou kara marc madiot
est un jeune malien
enfin en septembre 2017 qui a sauvé un
enfant laissé sans surveillance par ses
parents est suspendu à son balcon on va
revoir l'extrait la vidéo est
impressionnante
il a mis trente secondes pour monter et
la vidéo a déjà fait plus de 5 millions
de vues il sera avec nous dans un
instant avec son cousin les gars y'a
nous voir regardez
[Applaudissements]
ap
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous faire l'honneur d'être avec nous ce
soir
si vous vous allez 22 dans vos et
originaire du mahdi vous avez quitté le
mali en 2013
vous êtes passé par le niger le burkina
faso la libye et ensuite vous avez pris
un bateau jusqu'en france
et hier il se passe cette chose
incroyable et c'est vrai que depuis
vous êtes le garçon qui fait le plus de
plateaux télé en france c'est incroyable
ça ça va vous avez passé une journée
formidable racontez-nous juste cette
journée vous avez vous avez vu le
président de la république veut aller à
l'elysée
aujourd'hui oui aujourd'hui oui tu sues
c'est un cc foule alors si vous êtes
venu et que votre frère 1 voilà est
cette fois vraiment votre vie a changé
depuis hier parce que vous n'aviez pas
vos papiers vous avez vos papiers
aujourd'hui ça vous voulez qu'on qui
sait si c'est çà et là vous passez donc
dans la rue
et qu'est ce que vous dites à ce moment
là quand vous voyez un enfant vous dit
tout de suite je vais je vais intervenir
bon j'y chante avec moi commune
vous étiez sont chargés que ma copine
d'accord à la voulais aller regarder les
matières finale de ligue des champions
c'était sûr c'est vite bravo
et est donc est donc là c'est votre
fiancée qui vous a dit qu'est ce qui se
passe et ce au nom non on a rentré sur
les grecs comme vous on a commandé des
mages et voilà donc boselli beaucoup de
monde qu'ils ont décrié les bois c'est
les voitures et j'entendais
collectionner ouais bon je suis sorti
j'ai vu un enfant de 4 ans je voulais
c'était sûr au balcon et voilà là moi je
me suis fondu de traversée de la route
font moins bien c'est fou parce que est
parce que heureusement qu'il est tombé
sur vous parce que c'est maxime kenny
qui passe par là non mais c'est vrai
c'est incroyable mais vous faites fait
qu'en fait vous fait beaucoup de sport
vous êtes with effet l'esports de passer
à la salle des sports chaque match est
dans le pré vous escaladez souvent comme
ça les immeubles non non c'est comme ça
vous êtes dit j'y vais voilà j'ai décidé
de monter voilà qui est incroyable veut
dire merci comment vous faire après vous
vous appelez ou bien vous avez entendu
salak aliments il m'a appelé oui c'était
vers 17 heures à 18 heures et on était
ensemble à montreuil d'accord ont sévi
bon au moins deux mois j'ai rentré chez
moi tout à l'heure elle ou il qui m'a
dit que non il veut sortir et d'aller
voir les matchs ailleurs bon d'accord
les docks est bon à la prochaine donc
lui les partis moi j'irai avec mes amis
j'entraînais palais comme telle force a
sommé je regardais jeudi mais les
squares il m'a dit mais j'ai vu un
enfant qui n'hésitait sur les méthodes
n'ont que j'ai sauvée mais non qu'ils
savaient qu'ils la police et pompiers tu
peux venir aider mais dites moi si vous
vite chez il me dit mais c'est la
remercie de romans de nouvelles adresses
s'appelle apple et je connais cette
série je peux venir le temps que je
prends la voiture entre montreuil porte
de bagnolet porta village a été avec un
péage
non corrigé sais pas comment je conduire
des arrivées le temps qu'ils arrivent
vers la saper les kimonos qui vaut mieux
que vous faire un demi tour d'aller vers
l'hôpital lariboisière vers la gare du
nord n'a causé de oui bah je connaissais
avant d'arriver là voyage hyper wade qui
sillonnent là bas j'ai eu les pompiers
qui est de police et sont prêts à partir
après avec les brigades des mineurs qui
nous a téléphoné et des confine à
l'hôpital et qu'on veut les voir le
nouveau palais de justice à paris pour
être la vapeur inerte et animateur
encore
nous a confirmé que les papas c'est un
bon papa mais c'est un accident qui
s'inquiétait autres nouveaux pokémon
dans la rue c'est vous les élus les
parents derrière mamadou dans les
veillées sont l'échangé avec eux si son
père quand on additionne en bas voilà
et il est venu me saluer qu'est ce que
vous allez on y mange chez sal y est
c'est fini
d'accord c'est ça lui et aurait que vous
embrasser un mot doux aujourd'hui vous
êtes un héros
est ce que vous arrivez à réaliser ça
c'est vous le héros vous avez sauvé
quelqu'un vous êtes un héros
ça va changer votre vie à tout jamais
soit qu'il n'a pas envie de te répondre
[Rires]
gilles à dire qu'ils sont des gens ce
qui réjouit si tout le monde sait qu'on
a tellement souvent l'habitude
d'entendre parler de sans papiers
d'immigration en termes de chiffres de
statistique que lacan s'attache à un
homme qu'on voit ce qu'on est capable de
faire quand on est comme ça alors qu'on
n'a aucun intérêt dans un fair use ça
redonne espoir et j'espère ça fera
changer certaines mentalités qu'on a
tendance à critiquer des gens qui
connaissent pas ils sont pourtant
fantastique on les connaît
[Applaudissements]
est on vraiment vous avez fait un geste
incroyable on est tous fans de vous ici
vous êtes devenu héros bravo en tout cas
c'est vrai que maintenant vous allez
avoir vos papiers
un métier que vous êtes heureux ou pas
je mens c'est vrai aussi d'être très
heureux j'ai envie de jouer un gros
bisou passe
[Applaudissements]